foreign
[Music]
laughs
oh my gosh
hello
oh my gosh we're back
look at that in focus
Oh wrong way
there we go
oh my gosh we're back y'all
oh my gosh
only seven minutes late not that bad
I knew I didn't have time to shower and
I still did it
because I wanted to be pretty for y'all
because it's the new year
this is Bobby Sutton good morning
everybody Morris
says uh good morning
Joyce good morning Joan hi all
Joyce said Happy New Year as well yes
happy
New Year indeedy homidario was goody fam
as we say here
was goody
welcome to the right 10 Club everyone
um
we are about to write a joke live on the
air my friends Chris Ryder in the
building
oh we getting lit today fam
is that the microphone oh that is the
microphone
we gotta be we got to be professional
here we got to be professional here
ah
there we go
so yes we are about to write a joke live
on the air
I didn't have time to get Guinness is
that okay
with everyone
or do I need to go get him
hey
all right
so basically we're back
what's about to happen is
we're gonna write a joke live on the air
using today's word of the day
which is reach the word of the day is
reach I'm about to write a joke live on
the air
we're gonna create it together
[Music]
so get your notebooks
get woke
let me get this all set up here
for when we do write live
up Costa hello everyone
hello Costa was goody Fame
was goody Fame
foreign
[Music]
maybe up here I was trying to get that
book out of the way that's a bit
distracting
but it's what my computer is sitting on
oh alvato said can't participate today
leave a comment for the algorithm well
thank you
we greatly appreciate it there buddy
oh hey
oh hey well just to say what's goody
what's goody
how exciting we're about to write live
on the air my friends let's get
that
hilarious
yeah I'm here Jerry
I wasn't sure either
but
Yoshi talks some sense into me
how did I do this before
what's up John Bryant
it's
Akuma in the building
this is usually what I do before the
show but you guys are getting it this is
the new year
that's interesting setup
I don't know what I'm doing
I don't know what I'm doing today oh my
gosh
I reckon I'm a bit brain dead
I reckon that's proper English right
there we go that's better right
there we go
oh my gosh we 20 deep y'all what's goody
everyone
officially welcome to the right tank
club we are now set up
the word of the day is reach and we are
reaching for it today
we haven't done this in a few weeks so
we're shaking the cobwebs off
um
but I appreciate y'all
being up
hilarious
Bobby's been watching my live streams
too long
she knows me too well
some of y'all oh geez know me too well
I was just thinking that
Bobby said I love it when
Joel's coming off sugar it's ADHD at its
finest it is real bruh
it is
a hundred percent real
I was just thinking that this is day
uh this is day three off of sugar
I'm doing it on a calendar
like I'm in prison
I like I'm Xing off days like I'm in
prison
um
but it's not prison it's actually
liberating to be off sugar but
I'm feeling it today
three is when there's kind of like I've
done this enough times there's kind of
like a lull now
it was kind of like yeah we're doing it
and then the next few days
there's um
solid withdrawals already gave my wife
the heads up for the detox
um
Grump that could occur
but um yeah I do feel a bit sluggish
today which is great
time to write a joke live on the air
putting your reputation on the line
uh no big deal
but we're gonna do it
so officially
let's get into it my friends get your
notebooks get your pins your pencils
welcome to the right tank Club
the word of the day is
we are the right 10 Club
haha
all right my friends
here we go
we are doing it we are writing live on
the air my friends
welcome aboard everyone
[Music]
26 deep well welcome my friends this is
our weekly live stream
we get a new word and write a new joke
in 10 minutes today's word of the day
is reach and I am reaching for
the old Sharpie s gel
this is a goodie
this is a goodie I gotta say I really
love this pin
shout out to Jolie from rampantly
that made me hip to these pins during
the pandemic they're very good very
smooth they don't smudge wouldn't that
be funny if it just like smudged
everywhere
but they really do a good job of not
smudging
uh which a lot of like these Gel Pens
have an issue with but um
what's today's date is today the third
or the fourth
oh my Heavens it's already the fourth
where did the year go
so
um
my um
I'm writing at a weird angle today I
didn't set it up ahead of time so I had
to set up live so everything's kind of
at a weird angle right now
but um
that will that'll be my excuse if this
joke doesn't work it was a weird angle
oh nice Michelle
likes the S gel for sure
um Evelyn likes the Sharpie roller oh
the roller I don't know
all of these two too I mean I'm just
such a fan of these I mean these these
flare pins from papermate I just love it
uh Winston Hodges a great comedian
told me about
these these notebooks
uh they're like drawing notebooks
but they're like cardstock so those are
like really good to write with like
flare pins and stuff
a little more heavy duty but for this we
ride in the OG
composition notebooks
Michelle Van deusen said first pen
commercial 2023
I know we gotta get pin sponsors
we get these numbers up
we should get some pin sponsors
it's a good idea
who is active um who am I engaged with
uniball I've engaged with uniball on uh
social media that may be a good one
to a go after
look at the stationary discussion Jones
said I can't believe I missed it
oh and Jerry called me out it's 23.
not 20. I'm surprised you could read
that at all looks like it's
hieroglyphics but as I say if they can't
read your jokes they can't steal them so
all right
yeah Bobby the flare pins
they're legit
oh and Michelle likes the the canson
sketchbooks okay
I love stationery me too even though you
said you don't like the flare pens even
though you said you don't like the flare
pinch
we'll let it slide today because it's
the new year
but I could do a whole show just on
stationary
for sure
all right
how fun
well it is time my friends
I think now that we have this up what do
y'all think y'all ready to uh y'all
ready to write today
[Music]
let's get into it 10 minutes
on the clock
the word of the day is reach feel free
to comment
with ideas as we're writing here uh feel
free to share your own jokes in the live
chat
but for the next 10 minutes
we are writing
the inner gel is good as well yeah those
are good ones
I don't know if I have
any of those laying around
um
oh all right 10 minutes
let's do it
so how we always start these exercises
is with some light brainstorming so what
comes to mind when you hear the word
reach
there are no wrong answers here this
whole part is just okay I have a random
word all right what are all the
different things that come to mind
when I think of the word reach and it
could be
phrases with the word reach in them it
could be something that reach rhymes
with it could be something that reach
makes you think of there's like an a to
c where reach you go from like a idea to
B idea to C idea it's called a to c so
it could be
reach makes me think of the toothbrush
reach which makes me think of going to
the dentist or something like that so
you can kind of see you went from reach
to dentist
which is could be a bit of a reach but
part of joke writing is
creating that surprise well that could
be a surprising misdirect or a
surprising connection
so as I've pontificated for a minute I
need to play catch up here so
let's just go reach
toothbrush since that was top of mind
um
reach for goals
it could be
what does that word sound like as well
um re
each
so it's like oh I re-each one like the
word each but you re-each it
you know we're all brainstorming here
so what else
Rich toothbrush reach for the oh reach
for the stars is a common one
Reach for the Stars
is there something called like a reach
goal
um
Beach
Halo Reach have you ever played that
game yeah that's good leech
Jerry commented the Atlanta pin show
wait a minute
I gotta Focus all right let's focus bit
of a reach can't reach my toes all right
we got some good ones coming out here
um
Reach Out reach out as well yes
to reach out to that pin show no no no
no no no no no
um
reach goal reach so reach also when you
hear reach you're thinking like
physically reach
but what about
um
emotionally
what about metaphorically and what would
that look like
can't
reach now this makes me think so as
we're
as we're doing
um
hey Bobby I said people could brainstorm
in the comments here I'm not I'm not
cheating we're writing a joke together
okay
but that makes me think as we
do
brainstorm here the whole goal here is
to find things that you personally
connect with and how you can make a
personal unique joke so for me
can't reach makes me think of all the
different times people ask me to reach
for something
at the grocery store
um when something's on the top shelf or
whatnot
so there could be something there about
being tall
there's another phrase right bit of a
reach
I guess another one that kind of Rhymes
is breach
um
so being tall people ask me to reach so
now about halfway through this is
usually when I like to
kind of start honing it in finding
something in the brainstorming to then
start to structure into a joke in a
basic joke formula is set up punch
misdirect so
um
I like this use of Reach people asking
me to reach me being tall so now that we
kind of have an idea of what we want to
write about now it's figuring out what
is the premise
that I'm trying to say here so it could
be
I love being tall
but really the punchline is saying I
hate being tall maybe there's something
there
um so that's kind of the misdirect the
setup says One Direction the punchline
creates that misdirection
so uh being tall is fun being tall is
easy
let me just brainstorm some setups
that's another good writing technique is
you just get some setups out there what
are some different things you could say
around this so
um
so let's just get the ball rolling here
get the pin rolling
um as a tall person
to reach
something
um
Reach for the Stars reach for the sky
when there's a hold up that's a common
phrase reach for the sky
um Evelyn said next time you could ask a
short person something off the bottom
shelf yeah I was thinking that
um I don't think I've heard versions of
that from like tall comedians of like oh
well then while I'm up here will you tie
my shoe or something I feel like I've
heard
um a version like that how's the weather
up there
reach toothbrush
all right as a tall person
if I can reach
sorry I'm trying to
ah
this is a bit of an awkward angle let me
see if I can get around here
being tall
bit of a reach
what would be a bit of a reach
um
change the light bulb
top shelf
maybe I was raised
to reach
to reach for the stars
and maybe the misdirect around Stars
could be
um
in space
could be like a famous person
excuse me I was raised to reach for the
stars
but that's illegal
but that got me arrested yeah these are
all silly we're working on it we're
working on it
we're brainstorming here
um I like something about tall and the
reach
so there's something going off on my
Spidey senses there so let's keep
working it what am I trying to say
though
I it actually is annoying when people
ask me to reach things so
um I get annoyed
Reach Out Reach for the Stars reach
goals reach toothbrush
foreign
reach the top shelf
top shelf liquor
is there a misdirect around what kind of
shelf it could be shelf life
um
I didn't know when people ask me to
reach wait
tall people hate being told
could be my mom always told me to reach
for the stars and now I have a
restraining order
I mean you know
for 10 minutes
I feel like that's the best well
misdirect we could come up with in 10
minutes it's not terrible
it's not great it's not something I
would do on stage but
the whole goal of this
weekly live stream is just to kind of
get the juices flowing and see what we
can come up with in 10 minutes
um
I do like the premise around
reach and being a tall person I just
couldn't hone in anything
but for a misdirect
my mom always told me to reach for the
stars
and now I have a restraining order
or it's like my mom's worst advice was
to reach for the stars
because now I have a restraining order
it's silly it's not great
but it's done which is the whole point
of this writing exercise is just to
write something in 10 minutes so
good for y'all
I appreciate y'all hanging out
post your jokes I'd love to see them
and nice job everyone
can you think of a reach
I was raised to reach for the stars no I
like I get annoyed when people ask me to
reach the top shelf
X4
thank you
at six four people always ask me to
reach the top shelf
six four people oh my God
I hate being tall
but it went over their head
oh okay so there's something interesting
there um
uh at six four
or it's like
I always insult people when they ask me
to reach the top shelf
but it just goes over their head
[Music]
you know
what are you gonna do there what are you
gonna do I don't hate it I don't love it
but it's done and we did it and we can
say that
that in 10 minutes
we wrote a joke
good or bad it's all about the practice
my friends the name of the game is
you'll write 20 jokes and end up keeping
one of them so just
I'm talking about just lowering the bar
so what did y'all have I'm gonna post my
joke as well
um because in our Facebook group
we do a live voting as well and the
winner gets a fancy meme
made of that joke
so please post your jokes I'm excited to
see them I'm gonna read them live on the
air now as well so do
um
do poster jokes
in the live chat here and I'm gonna read
it live on the air
once I post my joke what did I say
cool beans
oh my gosh this pin show
how lit
interesting
that's fun thanks for sharing that I'm
gonna have to check that out that's lit
um never thought I'd be at the age where
I go oh a pin show is lit
let's get to your joke shall we
let's get to your jokes
oh see
uh
un momento Mis Amigos
all right so post your jokes in the live
chat just be sure to put the word joke
in front of them
so I know to read it live on the air and
this is so exciting yo
we getting lit for show for show
um so first joke I'm seeing here
is from Morris in our Facebook group
good to see you Morris
let me um let me get a little space here
oh
there we go
all right Morris a t once had a jingle
Reach Out And Touch someone but the
government broke them up so it looks
like the company failed to caress the
right people
very creative there don't worry that
yawn was not an indication of the joke
I like that
well done very creative using
what does rate reach make you think of
makes you think of
uh an old a TNT jingle very creative
there nicely done
uh Joyce
looks like we have some spam
and the uh YouTube live chat
one moment
nice
and uh stand up intermediate
uh you could post here or in our
Facebook group either way
all right Joyce my therapist told me
that I need to lower my expectations my
goals are much easier to reach
when I don't set any
all right
I like it famous told me I need to lower
my expectations goals are much easier to
reach when I don't set any very nice
seems like he had a breakthrough there
Joyce
she's doing the work people
um Chris Ryder
my mother always said Reach for the
Stars so she's banned from Hollywood oh
look at that
it's a nice parallel thought there
yeah yeah we ended up kind of going in
the same direction there well done there
Chris
um Greg
John Krasinski
John Crow zinski John Krasinski John
Krasinski
John John Carl Johnson
Joshua
John Krasinski is really stretching
himself when it comes to The Versatile
movies and roles he plays
he just signed a deal to produce a new
sequel to the Jack Reacher movies which
is actually gay spy porno movie that's
coming out next year it's called Jack
reach
boy that was a long way to get there
um
thanks for sharing though
I see what you did there
Jack reach around but I mean hey very
creative you took us on a whole journey
there
Joan Reach Out And Touch somebody isn't
the best song the last person who did
that to me landed in jail
oh nice
yeah nice use of reach there with a with
a song
well done a lot of people did reach and
then illegal activities it seems
glad we could really spark some good
inspiration today
um
not sure whose joke this is
let me know if you're still watching my
most impressive yoga pose is reaching
5am without having to be
nice oh that's a fun one
very fun
well done
yoga pose reach very clever
Mark I always Reach for the Stars
especially when the officers reach for
their weapons
all right all right smart man there
I'm not sure who I think this might be
Michelle Van Duzen I'm so short that
even finding a punch line for a joke is
a reach amen I was having that trouble
today as well
it's funny mine was a tall joke yours
was a short joke
and um same sentiment though
nicely done
[Music]
um
whose is this
not sure who's this one is
I try to maintain a nice personal
appearance so why do older women always
reach for their pocketbook
when I sit next to them on the bus
very nice
maintain a nice personal appearance
and you use the word reach
Bravo
next joke uh I finally reached the age
where my doctor doesn't say you're too
young to have such high numbers so
that's good I guess
oh oh that's fun
not that you have high numbers but
it's a fun joke and fun use of the word
reach there very creative
uh
uh D I am scared when he is reaching for
me as I reaching
to my car then I realized he is giving
me my lost car key
and then they said reach is rhythm rich
car
then I realized he has given me
lost car key
well glad you were safe there
um
Aaron Arledge
I was finally able to reach all the
bases with my girlfriend in high school
after my performance she sent me back to
the Dugout oh
my Heavens that's fun word play though
could use the word reach and then um fun
fun word play there of the bases and
then the baseball analogy yeah yeah
it's good vodka
oh I'm kidding it's gin
um
uh Sandy Bernstein I don't bother with
top shelf liquor for someone my size
it's a bit
of a reach
[Music]
I like it nicely done there Sandy bit of
a reach top shelf
I'm with it well done
oh that's good John gave an idea for my
joke
about being asked to do the top shelf
and reaching my limits that's good
well done
because it's being annoying I like that
very clever
um I'm not sure who this one is
okay
osmoris
um
second
my wife is five seven and likes to throw
things away so anytime I don't want to
something thrown away I just have to put
it just out of her reach that's why we
still have our daughter
noise
well done their Oz
protector a family protector
as I reach for the next joke
a new member Ian Turner all right
[Applause]
what's goody fam welcome Ian
uh
as a child I was told that my dreams
should reach my dreams should reach for
the stars now as an adult turns out
they couldn't even break the mold
all right all right dreams not reach the
Stars not couldn't even break the mold
yes
welcome to adults
and welcome to the hot breath of Earth
[Applause]
homidario
I saw my state senator at the
supermarket and was shocked when he was
blocking the whole path between the
shelves
I didn't think he was capable of
Reaching Across
the aisle
[Applause]
Senator Reaching Across the aisle
I don't hate it fam nicely done
uh it's Akuma
I got hit so hard in football once I
just laid on the ground and with my
hands up grasping at the air people
thought I was having a seizure but mom
always told me to reach for the stars
all right
Reach for the Stars nice use to reach
their fam
[Music]
um
Costa
as kids we were told to reach for the
stars that never worked out for me so
now I just reach for the Xanax
oh my heavenly day
well you reached for a joke there well
done
Aaron despiva I hate my wife's nickname
for me when I reach for things baby
T-Rex
hilarious that's a good pet name get it
pet T-Rex
all right all right uh Mike Marr
every time I reach for the stars I burn
my hand
I believe this maybe that's the oven hmm
uh Olga
there's nothing wrong with asking a
celebrity for reaching out unless it's
Nick
I just don't know who that is
but
sounds like he can't reach out
uh Julie my husband likes to reach for
me but I keep myself at arm's length
nice
reach for me arms length very creative
there Julie
oh Olga said he has no limbs oh okay
well then that would make sense
Felix
my Southern accent makes me mispronounce
phrases I mean to I mean to say please
don't ever talk to me again I would
rather die but instead my mouth says
reach out if you never if you ever need
anything God bless
nice
bless his heart
uh Bobby
on family trips I must have asked a
thousand times are we there yet I don't
care if we had reached our destination I
just knew it drove my mom crazy
[Music]
I'm sure your mom appreciated that
oh and Bobby said we have a nine-way tie
for first place
wow
so who hasn't voted yet
as we are coming to the end here my
friends
Jerry Kroll
my wife my wife salmon cheesecake was
jokingly named most interesting dessert
in a baking contest
it's a bit of a reach she now calls it
her award-winning recipe
that sounds true I like how you went
personal there Jerry salmon cheesecake
I mean salmon and cream cheese is good
so I could see the connection there but
a dessert
a bit of a reach perhaps
Bob grunfest my Wi-Fi signal doesn't
reach the second floor it looks like
I'll need more string
noise
um
Made Up dessert wow
a d yeah good to see you fam
Michelle I read
about reach in Little House on the
Prairie I mean leech I mean reach the
leech I mean whatever
cool beans
Aditya
reach leech Beach
nice
a lot of ramen Aditya it is good to have
someone in Life whom you can reach out
to any time like my loneliness
all right
yeah that's a good positive spin there
did ya and you have the hot
breadthiverse to reach out at any time
as well
don't forget
um
uh we're Landing the plane here
Steve
humanely reached its peak with sliced
bread hasn't been anything better since
it's very true it could be very true and
now it's just the word reach there
well done there Steve thanks for sharing
thanks to the hot breath community
[Applause]
Adidas says I'm getting better thanks to
the hot breath Community oh
love hearing that
well good to see you Acosta
and as we are landing This Plane here it
appears
who do we have in the lead right meow
who is in the lead
let's see who we got as the winner today
but I'll tell you one more thing
uh
I just dropped a winner on my personal
YouTube channel so if you have not
seen this new video I did about fluffy
Gabriel AKA Gabriel Iglesias it's
definitely worth checking out I just put
it in the live chat go check it out and
if you know of you have seen it
share the link
share it on Reddit if you're on Reddit
share it on Twitter share it wherever
you are
foreign
and already had six thousand views
that's very exciting it's like
the
the most views any of the videos I've
gotten yet on the channel so it's very
exciting
because we're working to get this baby
monetized
um oh CJ Watson coming in at the buzzer
here
uh instead of making impossible New
Year's resolutions I went through my old
diary to see if I accomplished any of my
old ones I'm happy to tell you that I
have reached the following goals I got
my driver's license graduate from high
school and got married three times
all right all right congrats there CJ
thanks for squeezing in at the buzzer
there too buddy
and it appears oh Joyce Lyles
[Applause]
Joyce
Joyce Lyles is today's winner yeah
[Music]
yeah Joyce how fun
oh my gosh congrats
yay
well Heaven's the Betsy all thank y'all
for hanging out
as we do this every Wednesday
at 10 A.M
this will be good though we'll be able
to track
the progress
because I'm on day three of sugar free
and it's
I'm struggling today
but you know what
you all got me through it and I really
appreciate that and I hope
this show and community
get you all through the ups and downs as
well that's what it's all about so
thank you all so much for hanging out
I love y'all so much congrats to Joyce
for winning today
and um
ain't nothing to it but to do it my
friends as we always say here
angels on y'all
have a good Wednesday out there how
about it
enjoy yourselves
I love you all
have a good day
right
all right let's do it one more time
Angel's on y'all
thanks for hanging out y'all I love you
have a good day we'll see you next week
bye